[Music]
Wow and now we have some sad news to
report Hollywood has lost a true legend
Don Rickles has passed away after a
career spent insulting
well everyone and you know what that's
why we loved him today you say hello and
they show two seconds yes two seconds of
nothing what his Hollywood handle mr.
warm with sarcastic indeed he even
insulted our reporters over the years
why in heaven's name did they give me
you there's so many other people that
Mary Hart was dying to be here today but
we had a blast with Don one reason we
loved the guy
he insulted himself as often as anybody
else like when he won an Emmy in 2008
for a comedy special in 55 years this is
one of my great treats in life my Blue
Cross is waiting in the truck to take me
away Don died this morning at his home
in Los Angeles from kidney failure he
was 90 but kept us laughing till the end
just last December hurling insults at
Kirk Douglas on his hundredth birthday a
Lunger generation got to know Don from
his role as toy stories mr. Potato Head
what are you looking at yeah hockey puck
one of his most famous moments was
breaking Johnny Carson's cigarette box
while he was a Tonight Show guest what
the hell happened Johnny then came at
him while Don was shooting CPO Sharkey
next door and then my wife and I put of
a beautiful cigarette box which I think
he gave to charity
how nice but six decades of insults was
really Don stock intrigue it's a big
treat for me to fly all the way from
California to be here but it's kind of
money most times you know when the
curtain comes down it's usually a
35-minute people refuse to leave hoping
I'm coming back but by that time I'm up
in the room explaining to the wife why
I'm leaving her
[Music]
you